dieser Mann der jetzt in Brokstedt diese
zwei armen Menschen umgebracht hat in
einem 19-Jährigen und eine 17-Jährige
grauenvoll
kommt glaube ich 2014 in dieses Land ist
seit 2015 12 mal polizeiliche
Erscheinung getreten
2015 Ladendiebstahl in Euskirchen
Missbrauch von Scheckkarten in Bonn 216
gefährliche Körperverletzung Euskirchen
dann gefährliche Körperverletzungen in
Bad Münstereifel Ladendiebstahl in
Euskirchen 218 Körperverletzungen in
Köln es war 19 sexuelle Nötigung in
Euskirchen 22 Sachbeschädigung in
Euskirchen Körperverletzungen in Bonn
zweimal Körperverletzung in Euskirchen
Bedrohung in Euskirchen und das ist noch
nicht das Ende
ich frage mich sie sagen zehn Jahre und
mehr wenn jemand wirklich gewalttätig
wird das ist ja zum Beispiel
haben wir es da nicht mit jemandem zu
tun der unseren Schutz sucht der aber
seit mindestens fünf Jahren nach meinem
Gefühl eigentlich nicht mehr in diesem
Land sein sollte aber jetzt sind zwei
Menschen tot weil er immer noch im Land
ist ist das nicht ein Thema aber das wir
reden müssen natürlich müssen wir
darüber reden wie gehen wir mit
denjenigen um und da bei ihm spielt ja
anscheinend nicht den terroristischer
Hintergrund eine Rolle Motive kennt man
nicht aber auf alle Fälle hat er eben
doch diese Anzahl von Taten begangen
eben auch schwere Taten und dann ist
wirklich das Thema wie lange warten wir
dass jemand wie er der von der Hamas
wohl auch gefoltert war
nur sagen da kommt jemand ins Land und
zeigt diesem Land dessen Hilfe dessen
Steuergeld übrigens auch er braucht und
das ja auch gerne gewehrt wird wenn
jemand Hilfe braucht aber der kommt ins
Land und macht erkennbar von der ersten
Stunde an quasi Probleme ja und er verl
Hamas und benimmt sich hier wie die
Hamas ja und also so also er hat einen
subsidian Schutzstatus wir müssen immer
schauen weil was machen wir mit ihm
einmal Taten verfolgen und verurteilen
das ist das unverzichtbar in einem
Rechtsstaat und das zweite ist wie lange
bleibt er hier gibt es Möglichkeiten ihn
zurückzuführen er kommt aus dem
palästinensischen Gebieten das ist kein
Staat dennoch ist es nicht einfach aber
es geht gibt es Rechtsprechung kann man
auch in diese Gegend also auch in den
Gaza kann ich zurückführen das ist ja
das eine bei Westjordanland ist ja das
andere lese aber mit einem großen
Erstaunen dass das so gut wie nie
stattfindet
sie sagen es geht aber Fakt ist auch es
findet so gut es ist aber eine Frage
wäre warum nicht weil das glaube ich
schwierig ist mit doppelbehörden zu
sprechen dass man die Abschiebung und
dann die Ausweisung auch die Auswahl
sondern die Abschiebung vollzieht und
ich glaube vielleicht hier bei manchen
die mit diesen schwierigen
Entscheidungen befasst sind irgendwie so
eine erste Vorstellung ist der ist ja
staatenlos aus unserer nach unserer
Diktion aber natürlich ist das nur weil
wir ja kein Palästina als Staat
anerkennen aber er hat ein Land in ein
Herkunftsland in in dass er eben auch
zurückgeben würde kann und deshalb fand
ich so bemerkenswert das ist ja wirklich
Gerichtsentscheidung gibt bis in höhere
Instanzen die diesen diese dieser
Haltung oder diese Einschätzung in die
Gebiete geht es nicht einfach ganz klar
revidiert haben aber es findet und da
haben sie recht praktisch nicht
verstehen warum ich war selber in den
letzten Jahren war fast ein Dutzend mal
genau dort auch in schwierigen Orten wie
hebronn in jährige
Premierminister hat gesagt das sind
Kriminelle wollen wir nicht zurück also
die Marokkaner wollen auch
schwierig weil Sie angesprochen haben
teilweise gibt es deine Papiere
teilweise verweigern die Staaten
wirklich die Kooperation das Asylrecht
ist finde ich eine der wichtigsten
Errungenschaften die wir haben gerade
als deutsche die natürlich die Erfahrung
der nahtza dann eigentlich gehört aber
dazu dann natürlich auch die Rückführung
und gerade gerade von von Strafe nicht
geworden man muss sagen da habe ich
gewisses Verständnis für die Politik das
ist schwierig ist ich gebe Ihnen mein
Beispiel in Bayern zum Beispiel wenn man
dort mit Wirtschaftsvertretern selbst
mit der konservativen spricht er und es
kommt wirklich mal zu einer Abschiebung
gibt es immer eine riesen
Protestbewegung weil vielleicht der oder
die flüchtigen dann doch integriert ist
weil es dann Demonstrationen gibt also
aber
gerade erklären generell für die Sendung
heute wirklich wichtig ich weiß wir
reden nicht über Migranten generell ich
rede heute Abend nur über
schwerkriminelle ich versuche frage ich
versuche ich versuche
Leidenschaft denn auch als
Papiere haben und man sie deshalb nicht
zurückführen können und die
Polizeibeamten hier der regelmäßig dabei
ist wenn solche abschieben das ist ja
das ist ja eine fürchterliche Arbeit
weil die Arbeiten monatelang und dann am
Ende funktioniert es doch nicht und dann
hast du eine Sammelabschiebung von 300
Leuten und am Ende sitzen zwölf Leute im
Flugzeug
umso wichtiger ist und ich glaube das
ist inzwischen ja auch angekommen dass
wir sehr wohl über Asyl auf der einen
Seite Integration sprechen auf der
anderen Seite eben von der Kehrseite
Ausweisung und Abschiebung und
Rückführung und da das alles nicht
richtig funktioniert obwohl wir mit sich
starten Rückkehr Abkommen haben nicht
wir haben Vereinbarungen die stehen im
Bundesgesetzblatt völkerrechtliche
Verträge jetzt nicht mit Syrien aber mit
Marokko mit vielen anderen Staaten wo
Flüchtlinge herkommen und es
funktioniert nicht so und deshalb weil
die sagen wir wollen nicht und was
sollen wir mit dem hier und so
ob es eine völkerrechtliche
Verpflichtung gibt dass sie die
aufnehmen müssen damit nicht sei mal
dahingestellt aber wenn sie sich in
einem Abkommen eher dazu verpflichten
dann muss das eigentlich auch
durchgesetzt werden und es geht eben
nicht weil die nicht mitmachen nicht
kooperieren und deshalb jetzt die
Überlegung Rückführung eben einmal zu
versuchen dynamischer zu gestalten indem
wir einen haben der jetzt bevollmächtigt
ist der verhandelt
hat einmal das mit Ghana gemacht in
Nordrhein-Westfalen da war quasi die
Vereinbarung die nehmen eben
Flüchtlinge Asylbewerber die nicht hier
bleiben konnten die abgeschoben werden
mussten aus welchen Gründen auch immer
nehmen sie zurück und gleichzeitig
unterstützen Nordrhein-Westfalen die
Ausbildung von jungen Menschen so das
was ja auch ein bisschen zusammen passt
also so eine Art Jobbörse damit man dann
auch in eine legale Migration und ich
glaube das ist so ein Ansatz der ist
jetzt nicht irgendwie ein ein unserer
Deal sondern zu wie kann ich legale
Migration befördern und die die illegale
verhindern
also weil sie gerade sagen bringt
Migration ganz prinzipiell es gibt doch
unglaublich viele brillante junge Leute
in diesen Ländern die wir gut gebrauchen
können ich habe solche Leute auch in
Russland getroffen die sagen in euer
Land zu kommen ist unmöglich in euer
Land zu kommen ist illegal möglich aber
egal nach Deutschland ist quasi nicht
möglich ich kenne leider Ägypter da gibt
es auch brillante Mathematiker wie ich
weiß wenn der versucht hier ins Land zu
kommen schafft er oder geht das nicht es
gibt riesen Behördengänge er muss
beweisen dass er genug Geld hätte hat
kommen da muss dazu deutsche Botschaft
da gibt es eine Riesenaufwand an
Papieren die erledigen musste und am
Ende könnte kommen konnte aber auch
nicht kommen aber es ist einfacher für
ihn sich alles Söder zu verkleiden und
dann sofort zu sagen ich stelle einen
Asylantrag einfach ein schleus zu
bezahlen ja und dann sagst du ich bin
Syrer und dann bist du da tja
ein bisschen ehrlicher reden müssen
Asylrecht ist eine gute oder
rungenschaft aber es ist nicht deprimäre
Aufgabe des deutschen Staates es gibt
andere Errungenschaften wie die
Sicherheit die innere Sicherheit dass
jemand im Zug sitzt und Sicherheit hat
dass man zu Weihnachten Weihnachtsmarkt
geht und nicht zu einer milit und um
sich herum schaut dass eine Frau Jogging
geht und keine Angst hat das sind Sachen
die nicht mehr wie früher sind und der
stark ist für diese Bürger zuerst
verantwortlich bevor er den Rest der
Welt rettet das ist völlig völlig
nachvollziehbar nur bleiben aber auch
dabei den Fakten wir haben keine
gewaltexion in Deutschland woher wissen
sie das so genau
wissen genau
ein Beispiel ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel
bei allen normale bei allen Male wo ich
durch Berlin gelaufen bin vor allem in
Vierteln wo mehrheitlich Migranten
wohnen wurde ich angegriffen fragen Sie
die Polizisten nämlich bei jedem Mal
handgreiflich beschimpft bespuckt kommen
Sie mit mir zusammen mit einem Juden der
eine Kippe tragt trägt und mit einem mit
einer Frau die einen kurzen rücktragt
und mit mir alles Kritiker diese das
Islams und laufen wir zusammen durch
Neukölln oder irgendein migrantenviertel
und dann erzählen Sie mir etwas über
gewaltexplosion ich erlebe das ich
versuche
sozusagen
ich finde nur sagen es ist da geht der
Blick jetzt auch zu Frau Titz ich glaube
Gewalt ist grundsätzlich ist eine gute
Nachricht rückläufig in unserer
Gesellschaft das nehmen Sie
wahrscheinlich auch als Richterin war so
ist es ja auch dass die Statistiken die
eben schon viel geschmähten Statistiken
sagen genau das dass gerade auch im
Bereich von Jugendlichen und
Heranwachsenden die die Gewalt stark
zurückgeht das war der einzelne Fall das
ist zwar Fälle von stärkerer schärferer
Gewalt gibt aber die Gesamtzahl deutlich
zurückgeht
zu Ende führen bitte die wir müssen aber
auch
gut
als Richterin hätte ich jetzt noch
anderes
anekdotische Trennen von der
tatsächlichen Evidenz und wir können nur
mit dem tatsächlich was wir tatsächlich
in der Gesamtheit erleben umgehen und
natürlich das heißt hier nicht dass wir
den einzelnen Fall den sie völlig
nachvollziehbar schildern dass wir den
nicht genauso hart schnell und effektiv
verfolgen müssen aber trotzdem können
wir daraus denke ich jetzt nicht eine
allgemeine Ergebnisse und genau das
wollen wir heute Abend auch vermeiden
wenn du trotzdem sagen es gibt natürlich
einen Grund warum
das sagt es gibt noch ein paar andere
Zahlen also insgesamt haben wir
festgestellt rückläufig schwere Gewalt
vor allen Dingen unter Jugendlichen aber
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund war
2021 allein die Gruppe der Asylsuchenden
schutzberechtigten und geduldeten für
fast 14% verantwortlich obwohl sie nur 2
% der Bevölkerung stellen genau das ist
überproportional vorhanden das deckt
sich auch mit dem was die Kollegen auf
das Wall Street Journals vor einiger
Zeit berichtet haben gesagt die deutsche
da ging es um die deutsche
Migrationspolitik ganz allgemein und die
sagten ihr habt da als Staat ein Problem
ihr kriegt die Leute nicht in den
Arbeitsmarkt und gleichzeitig treiben
sie die Kriminalitätsstatistik weil sie
das belegt die sozial signifikant mehr
in dieser Kriminalisierung sozusagen das
Bild einmal zu verfolgen an dem Punkt
ähnlicher oder oder näher als als Sie
denken weil ich am Anfang angesprochen
habe ich glaube diese Debatten müssen
offen geführt werden ich gebe meinen
Vergleich zu den USA weil ich da lange
gelebt habe als Barack Obama Präsident
war als erster African American
Präsident hat er das ja auch relativ
offen in Reden genau gesprochen hat
gesagt sehr klar ist natürlich eine
Ursünde in Amerika es gibt unglaubliche
Form der Diskriminierung bis heute es
gibt die sozial Diskriminierung die nach
wie vor da ist gleichzeitig hatte aber
offen angesprochen natürlich gibt es
auch Probleme innerhalb der Tracking
American community es gibt zum Beispiel
das Problem dass viele Männer ihre
Verantwortung als Väter nicht gerecht
werden das Bildung eher ein Wort ist was
teilweise auf den Schulhöfen verlacht
wird und das hat er relativ offen
angesprochen und da bekam viel Feedback
dass er nicht wirklich ein Black
President sei dass er sich nicht
einsetze für seine Brüder und Schwestern
und ein bisschen ähnlich sich die
Debatten hier wenn es sofort weg sofort
ignoriert und gesagt wird manche Punkte
darf man nicht ansprechen das würde ich
mir innerhalb dieser Gemeinschaft sehr
wünschen ich glaube dein Leben
funktioniert
wird gerne einmal weil es von gefallen
ist neu Köln
fort jetzt wissen sie oder können Sie
uns sagen die Leute die dort auffällig
geworden sind und nach allem was wir
wissen wann das vor allen Dingen junge
Männer mit Migrationshintergrund die
dort gewalttätig geworden sind wie viele
Verfahren laufen da schon Silvester ist
ja schon ein bisschen her mit mit Blick
auf die Uhr laufen da schon Verfahren
hat das schon Konsequenzen für die die
da festgenommen worden sind oder nicht
nach meinen
Erkenntnissen ich bin aber nicht sicher
ob sie noch aktuell sind hat ist noch
keine Anklage erhoben worden in keinem
dieser Fälle
jetzt müssen wir aber sagen es sind
jetzt gut vier Wochen vergangen seitdem
und man muss den Gang eines ermittlungs-
und Strafverfahrens in Deutschland
vielleicht anders sehen als man das aus
US-amerikanischen Filmen kennt wo am Tag
nach der Tat unverzüglich Anklage
erhoben wird unser Rechtssystem
funktioniert anders unsere Rechtssystem
funktioniert ebenso dass zunächst das
Ermittlungsverfahren bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft also bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft unterstützt durch die
Polizei geführt wird und dann erst
Anklage erhoben wird wenn alle
Ermittlungen abgeschlossen sind so dass
also der der Zeitraum der bisher
vergangen ist diese vier für eineinhalb
Wochen jetzt sicher noch nicht ähm ein
eine besonders langer Zeitraum ist damit
trotzdem immer Fragen von der Tat bis zu
Konsequenz also von dem Moment wo der
sich komplett daneben benimmt bis zu dem
Moment an dem immer das erste Mal spürt
dass er sich daneben genommen hat wie
lange dauert das was würden Sie sagen
die Zahlen die die durchschnittlichen
Werte sind leider gestiegen in den
letzten Jahren was sich auch woran sich
eben auch zeigt dass die gerade die
Strafjustiz eklatant unterbesetzt ist
bei den Amtsgerichten dauert es
meines Wissens hat 2021 aktuell
circa 5,8 Monate gedauert also sechs
Monate
knapp sechs Monate bei den Landgerichten
8,2 also gut 8 Monate
das heißt dann erinnert er sich ja schon
gar nicht mehr daran was eigentlich
verzapft hat gut ähm wir sprechen ja
natürlich jetzt bei Straftaten an den
landete den Landgerichten angeklagt
werden in der Regel doch über erhebliche
Kriminalität über schwere Straftaten
Sanitäter einfach zu beschießen ist eine
schwere Straftat für mich ohne Zweifel
können auch dort auch Straftaten
gegangen worden sein sind sicher
begangen worden wo es auch Anklagen zu
den Landgerichten geben wird ich wollte
damit nur sagen das sind oft Fälle in
denen sich auch ein Angeklagter im Haft
befindet so dass er natürlich schon
fortwährend auch spürt dass er hier eine
Straftat begangen hat und dass er auch
entsprechend geahndet wird
aber die allermeisten sind ja gar nicht
inhaft also
jedenfalls
ist es sicherlich so dass wir als
Strafjustiz
das ist sehr wichtig ist dass wir
Strafjustiz schnell möglichst schnell
und möglichst effektiv da auch
durchgreifen können die Höhe wenn ich
darüber wenn ich da noch kurz darauf
eingehen darf die wenn immer gefordert
wird dass man schärfere Strafen
verhängen muss dann ist das nach allem
was wir als soziologischen Erkenntnissen
wissen gar nicht das Entscheidende
Strafe
es geht um Geschwindigkeit genau
die Effektivität mit der agieren und da
sind wir eben
jetzt auch nach dem
tausend strafrechte eingestellt werden
sollten jetzt zuletzt man könnte
natürlich auch manchmal darüber
nachdenken ob man sich nicht vielleicht
verzettelt bei den falschen Delikten
also man könnte auch überlegen ob es
bagatell Delikte wirklich noch immer
Strafverfahren und geregelt werden
müssen ob Schwarzfahren wirklich Ja oder
Nein
90 Verhandlungstage auf dem auf der Uhr
hat ja wenn man sich da wirklich um
andere Dinge ja das ist ein Prozess der
dauert 90 Tage ja also ich weiß nicht
wenn wir uns das auf der anderen Seite
leisten ich finde es ja gut dass wir
gründlich aufklären aber irgendwann mal
muss man mal sagen ganz neulich ein sehr
interessantes Stück dazu bei den
Kollegen der der FAZ empfehle ich sehr
das mal zu lesen der
Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann
zitiere wenn Menschen dem Rechtsstaat
auf der Nase herumtanzen dann muss er
Zähne zeigen und diese Zähne hat der
Rechtsstaat auch wenn sie sagen das
dauert bis zu acht Monaten für mich
klingt das eher nach Gebiss
ich denke wir müssen schon sehen die
Gesamtdauer des Verfahrens ist das wovon
ich gesprochen habe und da sind wir eben
wieder bei dem Punkt viele Straftaten
sind im Komplex in der Aufklärung es ist
eben nicht so dass man sagt ach ja
wunderbar hier haben wir den Täter ist
alles klar ich kann in den zwei Wochen
Anklagen viele Ermittlungen sind einfach
komplett einen Tag Nachweis zu führen
womöglich überhaupt erst den Täter zu
ermitteln das ist eben nicht was sich
was ich so wie man sich aus dem
sonntagskrimi kennt was ich in 90
Minuten erledigen wird sondern das ist
eben etwas was auch Monate was teilweise
auch Jahre dauern kann und auch solche
Verfahren gehen ja in diese gesamte
Statistik ein das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen dabei es ist also nicht so
dass der Rechtsstaat um im gebissbild zu
bleiben ein zahnloser Tiger wäre
trotzdem gerne damit mal fragen der
im Vorfeld irgendwo habe ich das gelesen
wir mal als Übersetzer an deutschen
Gerichten gearbeitet was haben sie da
erlebt ich habe Gerichten auch im
Gefängnissen
übersetzt und mir ist aufgefallen
natürlich dass solche Fälle
überproportional sind also Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund und das dass sie
nicht vermittelt bekommen dass das die
zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden oder das
selbst wenn sie zur Rechenschaft gezogen
werden dass das dass ihnen das das Recht
ist und das ist die Gerechtigkeit ist
sie leben eine Opferrolle und Denken mir
sollte hier nichts passieren
und der deutsche Staat hat mir nicht zu
sagen und wenn wenn Sie mit mir auf
Arabisch geredet haben haben sie
wirklich ganz abfällige Worte benutzt
gegen Richter selbst gegen den eigenen
Licht Anwalt dass sie alle unter eine
Decke stecken und dass sie alle
Ungläubige sind und das ist das narrativ
dass sie auch von zu Hause mitbringen
manchmal und ich für allgemeine nicht
aber es gibt Familien die einfach sagen
die deutsche Gesellschaft das sind
Ungläubiger den kann man nicht vertrauen
Gerechtigkeit gibt es bei ihnen sowieso
nicht
sie glaube nicht an Allah sie haben Sex
vor der Erde trinken Alkohol also wir
jetzt
westliche Gesellschaft man kann sie
nicht respektieren und so kann man auch
gegen sie alles eigentlich äh das Reden
über Sozialisierung oder worüber reden
wir reden über Sozialisierung wir reden
über eine Kultur die
[Musik]
sehr in eine assymmetrie zum Westen
steht ich weiß man redet ungern gerne
darüber und man schnauft sehr schnell
wenn sowas kommt es gibt also mit drin
es gibt Unvereinbarkeiten zwischen
bestimmten Wertesystem und wer aus ein
streng gläubigen religiösen Familie
kommt auch wenn er selbst nicht streng
religiös ist kommt mit viel Geschichte
im Gepäck Islam und der Westen Kreuzzüge
Kolonialismus
der der Konflikt mit der Türkei dann
irgendjemand einen Koran in Schweden
verbrennt dann ist der ganze Westen der
jetzt den Islam vernichten wird pauschal
geredet das weiß ich nicht stimmt ja
völlig das ist diese Menschen selbst
Friedrich Merz hat ja recht das ist
diese also kann man mit jedem
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer sprechen dass es
solche Fälle gibt dass eben Eltern zu
Hause ein völlig falsches Bild auch des
deutschen Staates und das Ziel ist von
Integration vermitteln glaube ich
umgekehrt hilft uns noch nicht weil wir
müssen ja auch an diese
Bevölkerungsgruppen als deutsche
trotzdem gleichzeitig das Signal senden
wir wollen auch dass ihr hier akzeptiert
werden wenn wir natürlich die Tür ist
völlig zu machen viel
Integrationsangebote mittlerweile aber
keine erkennbare integrationsgebote es
gibt kaum Sanktionen
nennen Sie mir einige Gebote es gibt ein
ganz klares Gebot dass wir auf den äh
auf dem Grund des Grundgesetzes stehen
dass das die demokratische Ordnung der
wir uns verpflichten werden das ist mir
zu allgemein
steckt in der Details wenn ja wenn wir
von Werte sprechen wo ist der Wert von
Gleichberechtigung von Mann und Frau
warum fliegen deutsche Feministinnen aus
wenn man wenn man sie falsch gendert
aber schweigen sie zur zu Stellung der
Frau innerhalb von Migranten Familien
und man betrachtet das sogar alles
weißer Rassismus wenn man das
thematisiert
Grundgesetz sein das Grundgesetz ist in
der Frage ganz ganz klar wenn es darum
geht dass
es eben diese Form von von
Gleichberechtigung geben muss also
insofern das als Grundordnung ist sehr
sehr stark natürlich man muss es absolut
sanktionieren wenn das so geschieht nun
kann man natürlich nicht pauschal sagen
wir machen jetzt die Tür völlig zu und
wollen gar nicht das Signal aussenden
ihr könnt irgendwann auch hier ankommen
und deutsche werden das Signal ist
genauso wichtig und das gewinnst du
nicht bei Debatten die du mit kleinen
Tasche aber aber er hat natürlich einen
Punkt also wenn wir es nicht schaffen
sagen an der Stelle klar zu sein als
Gesellschafter noch mal wir reden heute
über kriminelle wenn das gar nicht
schaffen klar zu sein woher soll dann
auf der anderen Seite die Akzeptanz
genau für Migration für die Tatsache
dass wir natürlich Facharbeiter brauchen
so woher soll die kommen dann ist das
absolut das ist schwierig absolut
wichtig und das Problem haben ja viele
Einordnung Nationen also noch mal der
amerikanische Vergleich früher war es
ganz klar wenn du nach Amerika ein
anders also deutsche hier und so weiter
wolltest du Amerikaner werden und das
war eine erklärte Zielen die hat sich
voll identifiziert mit der Gesellschaft
so das ist in den vergangenen Jahren
dort auch ins Rutschen gekommen weil
manche noch die Verbindung zum Alten
Land zu Mexiko oder so weiter halten
sich nicht so identifizieren mit der mit
der amerikanischen Nation also ähnliche
Probleme und bei uns ist es natürlich
auch ein Problem wenn es ein
Parallelgesellschaften bilden wenn die
Leute noch weiter in ihre Sprache
sprechen unter sich bleiben also in
Deutschland muss zum Beispiel ganz klar
sein um beruflichen Erfolg zu haben
musst du Deutsch lernen das ist so und
das muss auch von zu Hause
Gebote dass wir nicht in der Lage sind
umzusetzen wo ist das Gebot das sagt ein
eine sechsjährige die in die Schule
kommt egal wo in Köln in Bayern wo auch
immer in Hamburg läuft erstaunlich gut
die
ist gerade macht das ganz gut hier der
schulsalat oder zuständige
da gibt's in Hamburg erstaunlicher Folge
also es geht offensichtlich wenn man
sich ernsthaft bemüht aber ganz vielen
Stellen berichten doch auch Lehrerinnen
Lehrer da haben habe ich sechsjährige
vor mir sitzen die sind deutschen
Sprache
sie reden sie haben vom Grundgesetz
geredet und viele Politiker sagen das
Grundgesetz bei uns ist nicht
verhandelbar nein das Grundgesetz ist
bei uns Verhandlung wenn wir Kinderehen
zulassen dass jemand weil er Flüchtling
ist dann kommt er mit Minderjährige Frau
den akzeptieren wir das und alles seine
Ehefrau
wenn wir es ist steht im Grundgesetz zum
Beispiel ein Tierschutzgesetz ja es gibt
ein Tierschutz im Grundgesetz verankert
wer schützt die Tiere vor Schichtung z.B
wie Opfern des Tierschutzgesetz für
religiöse Gefühle
sowohl bei Muslimen alles auch bei Juden
das ist äh das muss man auch klar sagen
wie
Opfern das Grundgesetz im Grundgesetz
ist das Recht auf freie persönliche
Entfaltung des Individuums ein Artikel 2
verankert wer ist die wo ist dieses
Recht bei einem jungen Mädchen das
religionsvereinnahmt wird ein Kopftuch
im Alter von sechs Jahren trägt und in
die Schule geht eigentlich verängstigt
und ein so wie ein Korsett trägt wo ist
der Staat der dieses Mädchen ermöglicht
ihre Persönlichkeit frei wirklich zu
entfalten